why I gave you multiple point look I
wanna you can have whatever you want you
can talk about my plunging neckline you
can talk about the fact that I won't pee
in front of other people or the
fountains in London what I love is that
this whole thing even started with Troy
going Mike are you okay are you like no
I'm not good not good
all right hi everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen I'm Alana I
am joined by Austin wintry Tribeca and
Mike Biffle all of whom walk in the
games industry in multiple full-time
capacities and today oh hang on let me
just hold mine up to is we all have to
do it Austin do you know wait is yours
maggot mine is hot yeah that's weird
[Laughter]
today we're gonna talk about and I'm
actually pretty excited to talk to you
guys about this because I've spoken to
everyone about my narrative we're
actually playing tail I'm so sorry
precise aspects of the lost of us mug
team I wanted to talk about some of the
very unique things that I think that it
does and definitely the sound as well
which I hope you paid attention to
Austin as sound guy I'm ambivalent great
just for public purposes can we get a
read on where everyone is at progress
wise roll credits finished it rolled its
same-same III I powered through
especially because obviously we had to
push this recording back a couple days
and I really wanted to finish it in time
for the initial recording date but also
just out of self-preservation on Twitter
and Instagram I was like I I know that
it's a minefield of spoilers and if I
don't do this I may as well so yeah one
of the spoilers that I had read before
finishing it did not turn out to be true
which is funny people were making up
things
so like there's like there was a spoiler
about one major character dying that
didn't and I was like okay well I
appreciate that I didn't know that I
heard far more characters Leo this
person dies and this person dies and
this person dies I was like no you got
all of those wrong there's no die that
don't boil or I had that ended up not
being true hey Lia which I was like very
interested to see if it happens or not
and I don't think that this is a spoiler
for me to tell you that it's not a
spoiler Mike because it's ridiculous
anyway but I was like no maybe yeah I
know anyone who's not finished it and to
be clear like with everyone on this
school like I'm fine with like within
reason like don't spoil like major plot
points but I don't care if we talk about
like levels I've not seen or enemies WLF
wanted to kill Ellie because they were a
homophobic organization and I was like I
thought there would be a strange choice
I wonder how they're gonna pull that off
and for the we know motivated one as
well to try to try and do this also just
how that you would even know that yeah
you throw a bucket of facts out as as
leaks without any context and so people
start drawing their own conclusions in
there they start mixing groups and
saying oh then this that's what these
people are and the devil FRR this
religious zealot group that are
homophobic and was like no you're not
you're not right at all you're
completely off-base it's like newscasts
I love the one at that that obvious
trance I'm like okay no the point is she
could be but also it's never brought up
and completely irrelevant Austin I just
made that is like you she turned herself
into a machine it's like that's he
absolutely what happened like well
that's also a one that I found tough
talking to people about because people
keep I feel like there are a lot of
people saying they've played this game
here haven't and they're like how did
Abby possibly in this world get that way
and like have you seen her complex have
you heard all of those gameplay segments
which one in cut scenes where she
constantly talks about not wanting to
miss training and how important training
is though yeah she also goes over like
her motivation for deciding against raw
is being useful to an organization where
she's been kind of cost out in the world
with no allegiances so she turns into a
soldier so she's useful to them it's
like very quite well exploit like
they'll also hood Jim he is why she does
it
I also think that just from a super
basic world building standpoint there's
no way that every single surviving human
is not ripped to a certain degree just
to get out of the [ __ ] they have to
endure just to literally live day by day
that's all you do in your spare time
right like there is no such thing as
spare time that's the thing it's like I
want to have a sandwich so I'm gonna go
battle through 50 clickers and like
violent Naughty Dog set pieces of rollin
through the floor and all this and then
I'll get my sandwich and then I'm gonna
head bad it's like a week of that and
everybody's just like you know I mean
it's just it's all it's do you are a
paleo man like you go forage for your
food yeah I thought I thought that the
reactions to the leak were leaks and
like the kind of cherry-picking of facts
and then building narratives that turned
out not to be true reminded me very much
of when if you're watching lies new live
news coverage of massive Supreme Court
decisions where they basically hand
their journalists like here's this
decision and it's a hundred page
document and the person I've seen this
where they literally they run towards
the cameras holding a thing they have
not read and they're like flipping
through looking for keywords and going
oh so it looks like you know justice
Stevens said this and this and they're
like trying because they have live TV
they're you know it's 24/7 so they're
desperately trying to glean like an
official legal opinion in real time it's
such a train wreck they always miss
report they always say things that are
out of context or they're misquoting and
it's like a week later the dust is
settled and people are saying here's
what it actually said to bring it back
to to design I am really curious I
almost want to be like a fly on the wall
this thing because I want to know Ilana
you I know you're you're incredibly
[Music]
stringent in particular like you have
when it comes to design I'm really
curious to see I know what you there are
some thoughts you shared about the
narrative I am really curious to see
what you thought of the design and I
want to know what Mike thought of that
design I'm I have a question before you
answer that but that if no I because I'm
curious I want to know your opinion as a
framing device on this conversation is
it worth I know Mike that this would be
a very tentative answer from from you
but from the from the two of you from
Troy and Alana I'm very curious
you're just top level review troyius
maybe completely impossible for you to
give any sense of but I'm curious if
it's good or bad to listen through the
lens of I loved it or I have mixed
thoughts or I hated it or whatever in
between versus just here's the minutia
of like this specific you know what I'm
saying like I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing to know here's
my thought on design my footnotes is uh
I think it's beautiful I really enjoyed
the gameplay whereas they didn't like
the gameplay that much in the first game
so like I loved the combat I stopped
playing and immediately started playing
it again and there are very few games
that I do that with I have issues with
the pacing uh mostly I kind of think the
games too long there are just some
segments that I feel like drag and but
my biggest issue was technically a
narrative one in that they're just
characters that I just couldn't get
attached to so things that were
happening didn't mean as much to me but
everything to do with Joel and Ali just
repeatedly it was like kicking me in the
nuts like I cried at the end so it's not
good didn't know act like I was very
upset at that final cutscene um but yeah
I I feel like it like I do feel
positively about it overall but I don't
feel like it's a ten out of ten which is
the thing that you don't generally need
to say it's only something that even a
close do you want to get so many ten out
of ten all right Mike or me who's going
next well either I might give you my
feeling so far on yeah I'm curious where
it's trending currently it's almost
identical to one
I think mechanically it's really came
together it feels like it feels like a
nice second pass I love the ideas from
the first game in a way that I like
beautiful to look at amazing technical
skill across the board narrative Lee I
am because I'm not called in to the end
yet like I'm definitely like where's
this going is this like from a pacing
point of view there's it doesn't I don't
have a sense of what its building
towards or where it's going which is
exciting I think the thing I said
someone the other day was like so far I
love the narrative design but I don't
think I like the story I like how it's
telling its story I just don't know if I
like the story yet but as I'm not
finished yet obviously I feel
interesting distinction I feel like I
would like to get into that for people
who have Troy I feel after playing it
that I there is not a single moment that
is not earned there is not a single
element to the story that is not
thoughtfully methodically carefully
curated and what it I've never had a
game either in narrative design
presentation mechanics anything that is
so rejected the notion that we must make
sure the player feels X and by and large
that is a feeling of satisfaction that
is a player feels this is important that
the player is engaged I feel that this
this game in every aspect where the
world-building the character the
narrative the mechanics everything the
pacing especially is like sorry this is
the story that must be told is it too
long yes yes
is it arduous yes is it exhausting yes
because that's the story if you cut a
single level and there's even stuff
where I was texting awesomes like I've
got to be done he's like no dude you
still have a lot more to goes like what
else can there be and that's the point
of this story because it the game
doesn't serve my desires at all it isn't
it it doesn't seek to make sure that I'm
comfortable and that I had a good time
it goes
sorry we're not there yet and in order
to get to that final moment you had to
have taken a step in everybody's shoes
and every step that they did I've never
experienced anything like it and I feel
it more than GTA more than Red Dead it
will and more than death training it
will probably have I would be surprised
if it had the lowest completion rate
vastly under what part one was simply I
mean it's double the length
easily easily as I mean part one was 10
to 12 hours and this is clocking in it
on average 27 to 30 so if there's rabbit
runs that have been but I think I still
think rabbit runs are hidden around 20
there's just someone managed to get 16
but I'm still confused by that because I
think that you would have missed the in
every part of the world building which
is like sort of half the point of a
Naughty Dog not only that but I'm just
as far as like Golden Path rabbit run
the thing that the game does a lot like
I there's stuff from like I'm I don't
want to be in a forest walk right now
talking to X character I don't want to
do that it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
but this is what's happening right now
strongly an agreement that they had a
vision and they stuck to it and no part
of this doesn't feel intentional and
planned and some of the things that
happen that I didn't like or I wouldn't
do were frustrating a watch in a way
that did not feel like it was a
disservice to me but that it was a bold
choice that a team stuck to which I
generally always want from creatives
yeah it was not a disservice to the
player it was a service to the story and
and everything in their services the
story but in doing so if you started to
go well let's let's just roll this back
so that the player doesn't feel like
they've been off the stick for almost 15
minutes at one point and that's insane
to do you never do that that used before
is 60 seconds before the player needs to
be back on this stick let's do a 90
minute
there is one cutscene where you have no
gameplay for like 15 to 20 minutes it's
at there are 11 hours of cutscenes in
total I would not be surprised Thank You
Gabe cinematics yeah I mean oh where
near as far
no no I mean the thing is the thing is
no I mean you're not even like your
nails have grown just long enough to
scratch the surface yeah the game and I
really don't want to spoil anything but
the game the game like the game takes
this pivot where you think oh wow maybe
I'm at the end and then you realize at
best I'm halfway and by that I didn't
spoil anything for you Mike because
everybody told me that was like okay
this is the point where we're gonna get
joy and you're always cresting over
another horizon yeah that was exactly
that was Mike which sounds from what
you're saying like that's intentional
absolutely nobody does that
everybody's scopes right you go we're
gonna cut this level we got we got to
cut this whole big set that's what's
interesting about this is like in terms
of like Studios who can decide to make a
game that is kind of making choices like
that yeah that's a very short list I
can't
resources the audience by in the
platform support literally that a game
like that so I'm but I'm glad some ways
that they're trying it exactly right it
subtly who can is like who does as long
as it is and like there is one
particular thing and I'm like I just
want to cut that like I just don't know
why I need to see that at all like it
felt weird but the the story being as as
long as it is very much lines up with
everyone's just [ __ ] and tired by the
end of it yes I was exhausted as well
and it's funny I actually started
recording I wanted to get my my reaction
to the ending so I started recording
what I thought would be the ending and
then it was another hour and a half
after that even though it's happened
what you're talking about and that's the
exact point that's the point of the
store it's like we could end right here
kro credits right here on a beautiful
shot right here but that's not the story
and that to me is what is so wonderfully
and beautifully tragic about all my god
about all of this do you think the
audience is less inclined to like do you
think the reason so many people have
been wound up and I don't know what
percentage of the audience is or
whatever
by that kind of bat vibe do you do you
think that that's just because the men
were living through is already quite
stressful and like you think this
would've been better received no I don't
think it's about T 20 without this I
think if this game came out two years
ago we would've had a completely
different response even with the leaks
even with the leaks we would had a
completely different spots the culture
that we have right now that is that has
grown over the last four years
specifically is one that says regardless
of truth regardless of facts regardless
of a mean empirical evidence my opinion
will not change and in fact the more you
tell me the more I will dig my heels in
and pour the concrete on my own shoes in
order to solidify my position period I
think I mean we certainly are in a
culture like that right now but I also
think because this game does so much
stuff that you don't like and you aren't
supposed to like I frankly think that it
is something that people who spend a lot
of time playing video games which often
serve as the player just don't like that
and I completely get that because it is
very unique in a way that it doesn't
give you what you want to see or what
you want to happen the endings is I was
just [ __ ] sad she's so sad and it's
it's it could have serviced me it could
have given me another hero's journey
like every other video game Joe power
fantasy yeah but because it doesn't do
that I actually think that is very
jarring to people who have played a lot
of triple-a video games generally
because you're used to a certain kind of
response when you play a video game and
not getting that like can make you
[ __ ] miserable like it really can't
and I just feel like that that there's a
disconnect between I recognize that you
were doing this to the credit of a story
which is how I feel and and I but I
still get the other perspective of
people being like this isn't what I
wanted to happen I don't feel fulfilled
and I get both sides I feel like okay
okay the some sides that I don't get
like I genuinely actually have seen some
just blatantly homophobic [ __ ] like that
can just get out of here that also
exists but I just think that this game
is so unique in the way that it
approaches storytelling
that it's really frustrating for people
and that makes me go well then I hope we
get mobile games like this because it's
doing something really different I think
that I think it goes further though I
think also the I think the fact that
it's a sequel that's building on the
very directly building on the prior game
where the first one obviously it to me
it funnels towards that discomfort for
the player like the first one ends up
where Joel is not really like a morally
defensible hero by the end like or at
best he or ambivalent about Joel but the
game it it kind of narrows to that point
at the very end whereas he's he's a
little bit more like he's a thorough guy
but he but you can project I think a
kind of traditional hero on him more
towards until the very end where then it
gets messy and it's like the gloves
really come off but then the thing is
with the second game you are starting
from that position
and just going vastly farther into the
realm of like gray morals and and really
just believe might be pieces of [ __ ] and
so it's exactly won't yeah so we're not
building to that as the conclusion we're
living in that for the entirety of the
game and that's why I think because I
remember Troy really stuck with me when
you'd mentioned I think it was last week
of how somebody like read the leaks and
reached out to you and was like this so
crushed me in the first game meant so
much to me and they felt like they were
kind of betrayed by the sequel and I
remember thinking you know that that's
just bound to happen because you know
you reach this very precipitous ending
and then it could go so many different
ways and you know I feel like the only
sort of savvy not to chastise that
random person but like you just have to
be willing to accept that this is gonna
go places you can't predict and that
you're gonna probably be uncomfortable
with just by virtue of where the last
one ended well it's I mean what we did
by and large as participators in that
story from an observational standpoint
players of this story
of the game we Davila fide and glorified
and hero fide Joel and so therefore we
absolved him of his sins even if we
wrestled with his decisions and we could
say we disagree with him and we'd
admonished his choices but we loved him
and therefore he became ours and so we
now possessed him hate the sin love the
sinner right much and I think pot to the
stuff that you see of Joel just made me
love him even more
also it was very specific choice well
like that was the one that I most
fundamentally disagreed with seeing
people say like this game disrespects
Joel this game makes Joel what a bizarre
take just the most sweet loving human
like he's stuffand and he's just so
[ __ ] nice and every time that you see
him he's basically fighting for Ellie in
in some way or another and it's so hard
to watch that and then also have to
think here's why people hate him holding
a grudge seriously III want to I want to
hone in on something because
specifically in Austin what you said
about what that person and by and large
what a lot of people have said is that
Joel did not deserve this he didn't
deserve this I don't I don't disagree
and well I don't agree or disagree he
saw Joel doesn't mean Neal that doesn't
mean neil druckmann made a bad call as a
creator it just means yes I don't think
that that like within the world
I don't think Joel deserved that it's
not a but here's that here's the point
but that doesn't make it a bet it makes
it a good game this world does not deal
in those terms exactly of what you
deserve or don't deserve Joel dying was
not a punishment nor was his living a
reward it simply was the whims of this
world granting him another day or not on
this business can I can I just jump in
with an opinion on the first game as a
story I think you're right
in terms of what I think the first game
told you it was about that kind of
dog-eat-dog you know real world or like
very cynical kind of world and awful
future but it wasn't in terms and I
wonder if this is where the destroys
happening the first game is a hero
narrative it is a story about director
kind of becoming a good man and and in
the terms of how the ending of the first
ones handles yes there's some ambiguity
but the game thinks he was in the right
like in terms of the text that's being
shown on screen the the upbeat guitar
solo playing as they go off literally
into the sunset he's the hero he just he
just saved the day there is ambiguity
there's nuance that's what makes it
great but the first game Daphne ends
with the idea of Joel is a hero who did
a good thing it's it's a it's a it's in
my opinion like I mean sure she played
him so I'm not going to tell you the
truth of it but like as a viewer that
that felt like it was it was a very
interesting kind of hero's journey but
it was a story about a guy who started
off with you know trauma he you know he
can't save his daughter and he's you
know he's he's he's a bad person in the
past and that's established and then
it's treated events of the story he
becomes a good person and he does save
the young woman it's kind of that
classic kind of hero with a problem who
fixes it is how I interpreted that first
game so I can understand that the second
game so far as far as I've got into
seems to be committing much more to the
central conceit of its world which is no
this isn't convenient this isn't the
hero narrative this is you know a
dog-eat-dog world but I can understand
why players didn't feel that that was
what the first game was the first game
was kind of it's it's kind of like um
the second is infinity war or endgame
the second one of those Avengers movies
it opens with like 40 minutes of it's
the end of the world but as an audience
member you know it's not like you know
that like we're wearing an Avengers
movie here sigh for me the first the
first the first game is Avengers the
second game so far is like Cormac
McCarthy kind of like that's the
difference I think and that's that's so
I can understand that thought process
even if that's not the intention of see
of all people made it
I think leaked so not people would have
been mad because the themes that it
deals with almost that to challenge you
know it it makes you do things that you
don't want to do and see things from
characters that you love from someone
else's perspective who sees Joel as the
person who ruins the [ __ ] wold and it
I get I get that no matter what it would
have been divisive I think but I would
really love to talk about the design so
definitely talking about a narrative
design this whole time I think but I
mean the one thing that I actually think
is yeah that I've mentioned a few times
now that stands out to me because no
game has ever done it to me before is I
don't remember if I mentioned this last
week looking at the clickers in the
shamblers physically disgusts me to the
extent that I feel like I want to throw
up and I've never had that in any game
before ever when my mouth waters because
I want to vomit
because these things are so well
designed specifically the shamblers yeah
the clickers get me when I see them up
close but then they're I feel like that
sound as long as improved - tone - but
then there's also like every moment of
you stabbing someone and hearing them
choke on their own blood and a dog dying
and it's just every man dogs but if I
may if I may and might this again this
is no spoiler specifically speaking to
design there's only one time where you
must the game forces you to kill a dog
you have to be don't you have to be
meticulous ly stealthy in order to
choose to die you could choose to die
but there's there's only one point where
you that the game goes now there's a
narrative beat that we're going to tell
yes I was too but I guess maybe one of
them you don't have to you don't have to
there's just the one that gets me the
dead dog stuff really really did get
[ __ ] sucks it sucks and I I and I am
NOT voix yeah playing it playing the
game on hill oh and I kept trading the
controller back and forth and she's like
a supremely hardcore dog person and so
every time one of those crossroads came
up it was just like this visceral gasp
of horror and I would sometimes
apologize in advance because like you
know there every now and again like she
would check her phone or something while
I was invariably exploring opening
drawers and crafting med kits and and
then I would see I'd see a dog and I
would just turn it I'd be like I'm just
giving you a warning of what's probably
about to happen and it's awful and I
hate it
and and so I so be it did actually I
don't know how you guys approach this
and I think this is like one of the
things that I like the most about the
game is that you really can approach
different combat scenarios in very
different ways so I went stealth
everywhere that I could and there is
there are two parts where I managed to
get through either without killing
anyone or just by taking a couple of
people down that were meant like
complexes that felt like they had I
don't know 50 people it probably wasn't
that many but so many that I managed to
just completely avoid killing anyone and
then to the end of one of those they
finally caught me so I just ran I was
like yeah not doing it just gonna run
and you can do that in virtually every
segment that has a dog as well I managed
to completely avoid them and you're not
you actually that the game is constantly
telling you is like if you are
outnumbered your chances or survival are
better if you just run this is not a
stand-your-ground blow them up and
everything it's like if you want to do
that now there's a part of me that now
going through the world especially with
the option that you have at the end of
the game to be able to go back I'm like
I just I will I've never won
an open-world Last of Us game with no
narrative I just want to go and hunt
clickers that's all I want to do I just
want to be able to go through and and
and like you would do any got the other
kind of hunting which you shouldn't do
but when it's when it comes to clickers
or shamblers or whatever the [ __ ] that
thing is in the hospital - Mike you're
not there and I I was just like Bravo
because it was goddamn I I died
there's an animation point that thing
was that that fight is very tough
because I had this thing where I kept
being like I just I don't know when and
it's gonna it I don't know I do how does
this keep happening it's it's intense
and then I like that they only really
relied on that that type of fight once
like that is that is very unique in that
game but um generally yeah the sense of
freedom is something that I feel was
very different to even the first game
it's a lot less I feel like maybe part
one is a little bit more uncharted where
it is a little bit more sure everything
why not it is also going back and
playing a little bit of it much more of
a walk down the hallway he is a combat
arena walk down a hallway part two is so
big and they do such a good job of an of
hiding where your invisible walls are
and also with teaching you what things
you can't interact with in ways that I
feel like most people probably won't
even notice like for example if
something has grass on it you can't
climb it and that's just something that
you're eventually going to get used to
is like it doesn't tell you that it's
just you one if it's green you're not
gonna be able to climb it it's over corn
you can't do that and this suddenly
seems like that but the Naughty Dog
yellow like we learned very quickly as
like God Naughty Dog yellow means is
something I can climb and then the last
of us green means something that I can't
it's overgrown don't touch it don't even
try but there were a lot of few places
where I was like I don't know what what
am I supposed to be doing right now it's
usually you have to climb under a bus
you crawl typically it's under I was
always down almost yeah I thought that
the range of motion to your to your
point Alana about you felt the actual
gameplay separate from the narrative
the core of movement combat exploration
all that even crafting to me I was so I
loved I love finding work benches and
customizing my gun for the sound design
of the disassembly of the rifle and
although all the metallic and and like
springs moving and the screwdriver and I
it's just I texted a friend who's part
of the Sony audio team and I was just
like mmm just like really real and same
with the clickers that that nastiness
the they're real like when you when you
when you come behind them and stab them
in a stealth kind of way I every single
time on hilla and I would say could you
imagine what that feels like
on like your forearms having to wrap
around this thing it's like cuz it kind
of look like coral reef yeah baby yeah
it like it would yeah and I was
imagining all these textures or I was
like well you know funguses aren't quite
as bladed as coral reef even though it
looks like that so I imagine it kind of
has some give to it
Sanji yeah like it really it really feel
that and and the voicing of all the
various like when you kill them
especially if your don't kill them
stealthily and they they cry out in
agony for a long time after they go down
it's that's really affecting after a
while that stuff troubles me like
someone begged me not to kill them while
I was playing the other day and I
genuinely like didn't want to keep
playing like it's it was a bit too there
is something but I wish there's a few
things like that yeah when you have
somebody in last stand you know to to
use the shadow of mordor vernacular
I wish well there's there's in some ways
you can you can let them go and they
will stand back up and they will
continue to kick your ass I wish that
the game would every once in a while
would have had just somebody run away
like there there's that that to me games
oh there's a rig
cancel my pre-order there's got
something that was informing that
decisions not be able to do there's a
limitation of the system or there was
like an in digital choice to not do that
but I would have loved
that's a shadow of mordor a thing like
you can let them go and they'll run away
they could very well come back but that
to me would have been awesome it's like
I let you go and that you brought five
more of your friends back is just that
that to me is consequences yeah I have
to say that two years two years track
that right to your point though about
everything being so conscientious you
know to me it's it's not a spoiler to
say that this is a game that whereas the
first one puts us inside joel to really
understand why he would make this
decision at the end which i thought as
hard and awful as it was as from his
global perspective as possible it's
really hard to defend his decision but
through the lens of like a father it's
so completely easy to understand
decision and that's the brilliance of
the first game and what i love is that
this one then says now look at what
sustained existence in this world the
gift that he thought he was giving her
look what this world does to ellie as a
result and so it's it's it's it's in a
way it's an elongated punishment of
Joel's decision as well and that moment
that first moment where it's not a
cutscene it's in the middle of gameplay
I distinctly remember what you're
talking about where I hit this guy and I
thought I killed him and then he's
begging for his life and and I walked up
and the system like it gave me a prompt
to strike him down and Ellie just walks
takes out like the wrench or whatever
and beats the guy to death and was so
like unsensible in doing so and I
remember thinking wow the [ __ ] square
button told me so much about where Ellie
is right now but also what does Dena say
in that moment I can't remember she
responds to that she's like Jesus Christ
oh yeah you're right yeah it's like a
kind of shock from there is a the system
it's not just like hey you got this new
upgrade now you can do this thing it's
like the system changed gave you a new
button a new thing to do and that was
informed by character and narrative so
that when you do that the world responds
and goes there's been a change in your
character
I've never seen a game do that - we're
in if it has done is like oh no now he
has X power but it was just more it's
it's it's such a cool way for the world
to respond to something that you a new
ability that you've unlocked to be able
to do that it's great of you having that
ability basically yeah in the same way
that you know the world goes she's out
you know if you if you're if you run out
of bullets which is great
that's a cool system to track but even
the world just kind of going we just
noticed that now if this happens you do
this that's yeah that that to me yeah
that to me there were a lot of little
details where I constantly felt like
this is tracking at least just descent
into darkness and like really
incrementally it's interesting how I do
actually largely agree with you Alana
that I felt that the game theoretically
could be trimmed a little it's like each
each engagement each area of the map
could probably have like 5% shaved and
the overall would bring the game down
where it would feel a little tighter
I do resonate with Troy's defense of
like looking at the world but I kind of
think of it like but right before we
started recording and Troy said hey
remember when you had a problem with
your USB and then I told the same story
but three times longer it's kind of like
that really like you did so with intent
yeah that you set yourself I needed to
really know all the steps of my process
to know I tested the different USB ports
now back at the story but I did back to
the bathrooms probably did
the audience wonder Mike I didn't want
to explicitly ask you because I feel
like you've spoken the least this
episode like it did you have any unique
thoughts you would like to share about
the design after last was part two I
mean everyone's losing their minds quite
rightly about the ropes the ropes are
very cool I don't know if like normal
people know how cool the ropes physics
the physics alone
well the physics and the the reliance on
the fit so so physics is bad like video
game physics is like something that we
never really rely on because it's it's
finicky it can go wrong it can breaks
across the board like yeah physics is
just not trustworthy you don't tend to
tie it to core systems you can ragdoll
an enemy but it's only after they're
dead and it's out of the way so if they
mess up and they always mess up right
and everyone's seen someone fly off into
the sky when Randall in whatever doesn't
really matter it's fine but to build an
entire like game mechanic about dragging
those ropes around is so bold and so
stupid and by the way like specifically
I was I'd seen people talk about before
I played it and the very first time I
had a rope puzzle it bugged out on me
and I was like artists ok so I read back
to a checkpoint so it's not perfect but
like wow it's yeah it's just great it's
very cool it's like AI K based physics
like making stuff wrap around clear
colliders making stuff have weights and
working in a proper way in that context
that's really cool technically like that
was someone's job for five years and
that's that's that's just impressive
it's it's similar to the again something
went around among developers but I know
if normal people cared the wine-bottle
in in Alex so yeah really great shader
which kind of people just admire and
respect though like when someone does
something so beautifully in terms of the
craft of like one specific aspect that's
the stuff I tend to resonate with other
than that I think it's cool I think one
thing I really like with I don't know
where it comes from on the team I don't
know how story works at Naughty Dog and
whether it's whether it's Neel thing
whether it's I imagine as a narrative
team
or a mission-team even but like the one
thing I love about it which again you
don't see in much games writing it's
something I'm always catching myself
doing is I tell stories about people who
are given a mission they go and do the
mission and once they've done the
mission they get a reward they go into
another mission where it's one thing I
love so far just even in the first five
hours it's is that kind of you know life
happening life being anything that
happens when you're making plans kind of
thing there are so many points just in
the first few hours of the game where
you're going to a place everything
you've seen has told you that you're
going to that place you have items in
your inventory ready to go to get you to
that place you have all of this set up
and then nothing it doesn't happen and
you just get knocked off causing
something else and that actually is
harder to write than people probably
necessarily think it's really thing
about being a writer is you know where
the story is going at all times so
you've kind of got to keep fighting that
instinct just to get the the Star Wars
action figures where they're meant to be
so they can fight and do the cool thing
you want them to do so having stuff like
when you get to Seattle and you get the
list of all the gates and you've got
like you know a couple of them are
marked up with the numbers and the
others aren't and it's like okay I see
where this is going all right I'm gonna
have to open that gate can't do because
of this and I can't and then you've
still got like five more on that list
it's like okay let's go through here and
we're gonna have to go over there to do
the thing to pick up and then you get
jumped and spoilers I guess but whatever
I'll have this point people already have
a game brewing for them like also
probably fair to assume you're gonna get
jumped a few times yeah yeah and this is
also very early in the game exactly I
knew but but that like genuinely like
I've seen a lot of conversation about
kind of the game and the story but like
yeah I think I think there are so many
things that games games are very good at
striving for the big things but we often
are like either have never done the
little thing or we don't think to do it
because we've not inherited the
knowledge to get to there so meant so
often like good game narratives are
usually on a par with like bad movies
like we we celebrate I Thomas was alone
you know won awards for its storytelling
anyone who's got kids has seen five
stories as good as Thomas was alone on
children's television on a weekend like
it's a pretty straightforward standard
story
I think that's true of so much game
storytelling that we don't get the
fundamentals and why I am impressed
within last of us is there's stuff in
there like that like the idea of a
character has a goal they're trying to
get to the goal and their course is
corrected by something that happens on
the way that's bread and butter of
motion
TV and fiction games don't do it that
like it gets the fundamentals lined up
nicely in the way that I respect I don't
know about the bigger picture but like
that deserves calling out Triple A games
kind of doing that is impressive to me
and just like getting the fundamentals
down yeah I one thing that I really
applaud them for is that I didn't feel
and maybe there's stuff that that was
there that that no longer was by the
time I got done with that I I thought
that there was gonna be so much that
from the original pitch that was cut and
if there's not like all the the big
there was a slightly different version
at the end but I mean I was sitting
there going I remember when Neil first
told me this idea and it pretty much
stayed true to that pitch like it feels
like this this is what end is this this
happens and then this happens I was like
holy [ __ ]
do you know was that in did he have a
sense of this before finishing the first
one like do you know like was it just
finished the first clean break start the
second or did he have a long-term
trajectory in mind he meta fied to the
purposefully he said I didn't realize
this he was like but he started coming
up with an ideas like I think I have an
idea when they were doing left behind
which surprised me because I thought it
was after that well after that I did
that game it shipped and he had some
time away from it that he was like I
know I have an idea but he said that he
started kind of where a Greg Miller
talking about this and he he said that
that idea first came to him with this is
what would happen what really happens to
Ellie like we we we really have gone as
far with Joel as we can that story we
got god we left everything out on the
dance floor with him there is only so
much and that's the beauty of their
stories like there's only so much the
Joel we need to Joel needs to give us
he's given us everything and it was more
about
what happens in the aftermath of that
making that decision and do we do
another story of him now trying to find
redemption it's like man we've hit that
we've played that guitar out I will say
something of speaking of guitars are you
guys seeing all the videos of people
playing their own music yeah I
this [ __ ] controller has driven me
crazy and I've loved it and I've hated
it but specifically this thing right
here playing their own songs yes and
recording it there's a dude that did
hallelujah and recorded he did it he was
I did a duet with Elly and Elly is
playing by the way you can finger pick
I've never seen the Norma it's like okay
strum right or you can go tap on it
somewhere props
don't worry about it
oh it says beyond from my genes podcast
Wow dude I didn't realize until much
later in that you could literally just
go this would be my top eithe is my
bottom me this is the a the D the G the
B and so people started doing like
finger picking and there's a kind of did
like a Twitter to to Neil and he does
hallelujah and I was like that's some
emergent design right that is someone at
add you know its own ego and you got to
do something that includes the trackpad
it's like ah it is the best use of it
the best use of it you know what's so
funny as soon as you remember the scene
and Family Guy where Stewie is doing the
songwriting demonstration but he's like
oh and then you see code so the
hilarious thing was that I pulled that
up and I was trying to play along with
that in the guitar bit with Ellie that's
the weirdest use of them I was like I
was like I was I got I was like I got a
parallel this and but the funny thing is
that the guitar doesn't let you play in
the key of G unless you play in the key
of C unless you play in the key of D but
it doesn't let you play in the key of G
so the only way to match Stewie was to
switch keys half way through back and
forth and I was like that's [ __ ] hard
to do accurately
feedback for Sony yeah there's some
weird chord structures I was like he
would never play that chord on guitar
piano you would it's like there's like
an a-flat and there's like stuff like
this I was laughing I was like they
didn't have her cape owing for some of
those keys I was like that that probably
would have been how she got there
well what's what I love the two things
that that were pretty funny I future
days is capo 2 so I I had to play that
song with with capo - the fact that you
would be able to find a guitar much less
a capo in that world was I was like
that's a beautiful stretch does that so
what I didn't realize and Neil and I
even had this conversation where I was
like man if I found this guitar this
thing would this thing would I mean to
restore this guitar and I don't know if
it was an afterthought to say that Joel
which I love when you go into his house
and you realize the guitar that he gave
her is not the first guitar that he made
like the house an indie game like you
could ship that's actually telling you
about the man is it yeah yeah I I texted
Neil and it said the house is the
funeral and the wake the front of it is
like a Beatle it's like Sargent peppers
you could just unpack so much about it
but like there's a processional that
that le makes to a outdoor space where
there is flowers you walk inside and
it's very solemn but there's still
there's the do you remember and we have
this this is everything that we do with
a funeral and then there's the
celebration of which is the wake and
then life moves on like that that just
to jump on that the flowers really
affected me because it was like what a
change that joel has ingratiate himself
to this community in contrast to where
he was in the first game he wasn't a
community guy but he had really altered
where he was in life to the point that
even though we don't see it the fact
that that many people would have left
flowers on his door
I really feel like you've retired and
that's like he became this guitar maker
he was chiseling I think it's you see a
wooden horse I think he's right I love
writing poems that the beauty of it is
that for for Joel to first of all to
reveal so much about himself that the
notion of him retiring is interesting
but the the reason why the flowers
affected me so much is that this is
obviously yes Jackson is safe because
they're there they're protected but
people still die they even talk about is
like oh those that the the people that
left like they've experienced loss so
death would they probably view death
very stoic Lee it's just like analysis
this is what happens and this is where
we bury people and everything else but
for Joel is like know that this was a
pillar of our community and there was
someone who had only been there for a
few years versus he did he wasn't the
patriarch of the community he was just
as old Joel did you guys find a gustavo
i only I saw a guy playing and I thought
oh that's cool and I didn't get close
enough and then I saw screenshots and I
was like [ __ ] that's pretty cool yeah I
had no idea what I did I probably did I
feel like I explored everything very
thoroughly as Ellie's walking through
and I still need to ask Neal if the dog
that you pet in the beginning when
you're walking through the town which is
right before right after you meet or
seek your topic he's sitting on a what
standing on a huh I would have I would
have done it it just feels like so long
ago now that's i think that i think that
that's buckley which is the dog from the
first game cuz she she she she says hey
do an old-timer
and so it seems to stands to reason that
that would be that would be like from
the little commune where you first find
Tommy you mean that that dog that's and
the story behind that is right when we
started doing that I had lost my dog
and
Neal had experienced the loss of his dog
and is very very traumatic for him and
for the longest time that was the the
biggest loss that he had had in his life
and the kindness that he extended to me
to be able to say what's the name of the
dog and I was like can we name him
Buckley he said absolutely he gave me
that honor he had every right as the
writer and the creator of this thing to
go actually I mean I I want that to be
my dog's name and he didn't and I found
that it that's one of the greatest gifts
he's ever given me and so I was like oh
[ __ ] I need to ask him is that because
you never say the dog's name I was like
if that's buckle again it's just that's
cool everything to do with bear got me
extra hard because my chocolate Labrador
his name was Chelsea but I nicknamed her
bear and she died way prematurely and it
sucked and it's like just still just so
awful
she opened by a tick dead in 24 like an
infection like a kill though and she was
on all the anti tick medicine yeah it
[ __ ] sucked it was very like I loved
that dog so much light of my life and I
didn't cry for 24 hours because I was
just so like before what like it just so
and I still I still haven't gotten a dog
because I feel like I haven't recovered
from that but no was that two years ago
I want to encourage you with the same
words that a friend told me when I I
literally was telling him what happened
to my dog and he was just nodding the
entire time he was like yeah man yeah
I'm like dude do you not understand what
how human emotions work in the fact that
I'm telling you an incredibly sad story
and fairness
you're also a robot and I said that I
was I literally was screaming in the
street and he said the heart that I hear
breaking reveals the capacity that it
has to love and I just know a lot of
dogs out there that need love he said I
would encourage you to to go share that
love it that got me but this is
definitely a separate conversation about
how now I'm just anxious all the time
about the idea that I would get a dog
and that something would happen and
there's can't do anything about it
but my point there was really just that
hit me
because the dog was named bear and you
hear them say bad I was just like
basically what you're afraid of is that
you're gonna get another dog and the two
of you are gonna end up in a room and
you're gonna be yelling at it like you
don't know what before we wrap up
there's another like design aspect that
I really wanted to talk about which is
so we've spoken about how open a lot of
the I want to say like combat arena Zhou
and
I have had plenty of instances in the
game where I've not known where to go
but then and I actually like that and I
think I've spoken you guys about this
I'm auntie using the listen button
always I just don't use it
I go to my counter I can without using
it and obviously it's an option for
people who prefer to but it meant that
I'm in this world that all of these
areas feel quite large and I just have
to listen or look and you I mean you
can't see a pretty good field of view
around you but it does mean that like
often if you don't see why the enemies
are you actually don't know what forward
is and that's a thing that the video
games rely on so heavily is like more
enemies are in the direction of forward
but because I have no idea where they
are don't know why forward is so I feel
like this game with again those combat
arenas being a lot more open than normal
does a very good job of hiding its
pathways and I don't know if I even told
you guys this before the thing that
makes a game my favorite game versus a
game that I like is level design level
design is like my absolute like when I
really think hard about the games that
I'm like [ __ ] incredible its level
design like Dishonored 2 is just right
up there does that mean that it's clear
to you where you should be going or that
it be it's more of a challenge for you
to know where you're going uh know that
it's smart about communicating with me
where I should be going
or that I have a lot of options so like
I've decided to I mean I could go ship
no time for several hours but the idea
that there there are options that all
funnel but doesn't do it in a blatant
way there isn't a you climb on list look
this ledge don't climb on this ledge
lots of a spot to like I'm sure I got
lost a lot but when I started actually
really paying attention to the level
design and the way that it tries to tell
you which direction is correct I just
started getting more
more impressed by it it's they hide it
really really well really good use of
lighting which is obviously a common way
to communicate to play as where to go
but they also use different shades of
lighting like often our reddish light is
used to indicate that they're all going
to be enemies in a certain direction
which is something that seems so subtle
and so unnecessary but probably after a
while of training keys you in to
anticipate that but they also use like
white lighting coming from a certain
point to indicate that something is the
right thing to look at they also use
that they faked it out with that a
couple of times there is something that
looks like it's spotlighted that you're
supposed to look at as a mistake like it
is it is red herring to you with
lighting multiple times in the game - in
a way that I keep being like hey just a
lot of a lot of really interesting red
herrings in the design I think yeah I I
I'm not trying to cut you off of here if
you're still going up now go ahead well
because there's one thing that I really
wanted to bring up that's sort of
adjacent to this slight tangent but so I
have a friend I know par for the course
there's just a story I've been dying to
share with you guys
yes so I have this friend this guy named
Brandon Cole who I met at GDC like five
or six years ago because he is a blind
gamer and he gave a speech about
accessibility for blind gamers to the to
the audio community during one of the
audio things at GDC and he came up to me
and told me this whole story about like
experiencing journey and and and and I
was like is that game remotely playable
blind he was like no no no it's terrible
and he was like it sounded amazing but
it's completely unplayable and hence so
elated this conversation and so shortly
before last was part two came out he
sent me a thing where he had been giving
a speech at a conference for game except
like a like a small kind of niche
concert conference about game
accessibility for blind gamers you know
motor control
like people that have issues with more
to control or court I hand coordination
or reaction times their various reasons
for whatever reason obviously deaf
gamers there's a whole subset of like
how do we try to make games more
inclusive and he was giving a speech
there because you know his whole thing
is he's found all these amazing
workarounds and games that like he found
ways to make them accessible that
they're not actually originally designed
for but there's just quirks of the
system he talked about how Resident Evil
6 is completely playable by him and he's
quite comfortable at it and by using the
systems in ways they're not designed for
and it's [ __ ] awesome we had a long
conversation the other day and he told
me that he was asked to give a speech
and he knew that there were a couple of
Naughty Dog folks in the audience and so
he gave this feature he said very often
when there's a game he wants to
experience his wife will play that can
play it for him and he'll just kind of
ride along and he said my ultimate
fantasy was that everyone talks about
how great the Last of Us is and I my
fantasy is I would always want to be
able to play a game like that for her
and not the other way around and of
course and he said that space sly he
knew there were Naughty Dog people in
the audience so they approached him and
they were like this is actually really
interesting and so for the like the
entire back half of development he flew
to LA multiple times and consulted with
them and they are now parading around
that this is the most accessible
triple-a game ever you can play the
entire section I did because of talking
to him I went through insane amounts of
customization are you just like Steve
Saylor or are you talking about a
different person my guy his name's
Brandon Cole Steve Saylor also put up
something as well that is just heart
heartwarming to watch he's a he's a
brilliant beautiful person who the
second that he it's almost like Corey
Barr log reading off his good it's Steve
Saylor going through and understanding
when he was like there's so much here
there's just so much here I got a
message from someone who was cerebal
palsey who talks about this is the most
accessible game ever so I for for Noah
that for no other reason than that
whether people agree with the design
agree with the narrative agree with the
characters agree with the world agree
with the gameplay agree with anything
else hate it they get the disrespect
whatever I've got two stories that for
me are like if we ship the game for no
other two people on this planet than
those two people that debt to me as a
win that's amazing absolutely absolutely
I think that excites me with
accessibility is it's just extreme
design like it's just really good
exactly and it's very interesting when
you look at like all of these features
they're useful like it's making a game
accessible and to be clear like on our
games where we're indie we often don't
have the time or resources to do an
amazing job of this so we're definitely
I'm not I'm very not holding our stuff
up as a Paragons but looking at
something I lost of us to where they've
done fantastically all of that stuff
then plays back into the main audience
you can go into who don't need the
accessibility features but that will
that will enhance their of their
experience like and I love that I think
that's that's so neat and it's also just
there's so many places where they've
made good use of it like the tutorial
pop-ups use the renderer that's designed
for the strong that I think it is at
least it looks like it's using the same
render it's used for the visibility mode
where they're kind of making characters
render different colors so even that
even just building that for this
community over here then allowed them to
put it in somewhere else it's just it's
it's a really good I feel like lots of
us who's gonna be using a lot of
arguments to just add really good
accessibility to other games it's good
question yes Bibles are really good -
you mentioned do you feel that if there
was a category for accessibility in
games just like there is for design and
character and sound and everything only
Awards yes do you feel that would be a
motivator enough for studios to be able
to like if a publisher quantifying oh
well if we get an award for this do you
think that that would or or or is there
just it's like man we're stretched right
now and like every penny that we get
from a publisher has already spoken for
and sometimes over do you feel that
because that I was not aware I've have
been tertiary lea where the conversation
of accessibility before but never have I
seen the benefit of it as much as I have
with this game and so I'm wondering if
just like the last of us before said a
narrative stand you know
standard almost for games and even the
way that Naughty Dog is kind of created
a pipeline for how games should
incorporate of triple-a status should
incorporate performance capturing it and
those kind of fidelity of performances
do you feel like they could do the same
thing with accessibility and do you
think this will change I think
inevitably well I mean the bluntly
everything in games is really expensive
and tough to do right now please go
please go away and leave me alone is
like be the default stance to any any
request that comes towards dev team but
we bother with narrative we bother with
good music we bother with good act like
we we can we can choose to put that
focus into it and I think yeah anything
that kind of highlights where it's done
well I think the other thing that's
really interesting is is highlight
solutions on game devs we we are very
good at stealing each other's ideas
we're very very seeing something working
someone else's game oh let's do that
oh that's good a great example of this
last of us that visibility mode they do
so anyone is going to things we've seen
this way you can switch it on it
basically makes like play a character
bright blue enemies bright red
everything else grayscale any developer
working in a modern engine and with a
good you know our pipeline and take our
technical director looks at that goes
that's gonna takes an afternoon up
genuinely anyway that is its shaders
essentially you've set up in the
pipeline depending on how things are set
up in theory making it so that all of
your player characters my art is tinted
blue all of your enemies are sent in red
and everything else is grayscale is not
hard hmm
once you've come up with the idea for it
the Nemesis of like you always say that
Mike it's more about who came up with
the idea yeah it's intended guitar solo
that's like yeah you could play it but
he did it first
that's why games keep getting better
he's because the first person does the
thing and climbs up that mountain and
works out how to get up there but they
leave the mountain climber but like the
stake in the ground with the Rope
hanging off so someone else you're not
about to close Stef's training believe
in ladders everywhere you need it
but that's important and that and so I
think everyone who's seen now like I
looked at that and I was like there's
not really a very good excuse to not put
that mode into future games from us that
kind of are doing 3d characters in like
a third person was like you know if
we're doing that in the game that would
make sense so I think that's that's
what's exciting I think yeah
highlighting excellence works
highlighting excellence I don't think it
puts like I don't think people will do
it just to try and win an award however
awesome this ceremony is in everything I
don't think that's the only that's what
does it I think it's people hearing
about it when Last of Us does it
everyone in the industry plays last of
us of course they do so all of that
stuff gets kind of pulled back into the
the mindset of everyone who's making
games but there's an awesome there's
probably an awesome indie game that came
out two weeks ago that had a really
innovative approach to like how do you
communicate for blind gamers you know
audio cues in the environment and I've
not heard of it I know else's heard of
it but if that was found by an award and
highlighted and celebrated that that hey
that team gets the credit they deserve
doing something cool but be the rest of
us I cannot reiterate this enough get to
steal it yeah and that's how the
industry moves forward in general and
it's it's it sounds negative and I think
the audience sometimes reacts badly what
could talk about this stuff because it
sounds like of stealing stealing
artistic stealing is the most artistic
thing like I feel like you have to like
everything still online and to the wheel
yeah exactly like we're all building on
the shoulders of giants and sure if this
was an area where we were where we can
see excellence faster than we can learn
from it and some things are technically
challenging some things are easy the one
that always comes up I think the
audience thinks is very easy but really
isn't is some font sizes making it so
you can make the font bigger on you eyes
that's one of those things there's
really difficult in the game all the
time just because sorry a very very
different way it's really difficult if
you decide to do it lost if you do it
first if you plan for it like most
things it's absolutely fine but if you
do it like if you release your game and
everyone says the fonts too small like
doing the patch to fix that is really
like really stressful and difficult
interesting because it's not word you
can't just like go select all the time
making a bigger it's not quite how it
works
would be lovely if it was that's the
thing is I think we don't need to
necessarily give excuses to the audience
or explain this stuff but by seeing
stuff out there we can learn from it and
put it into the games and yeah last of
us just absolutely set a yardstick for
us all to walk towards again like using
metaphors for you know mr. Walker on
this call before we side the court what
do you say I look tired I didn't say you
look tired I just write because you
signed on and normally if this bright
you knows cheery smile had nothing to do
that's what I actually was celebrating
the fact that I know you well enough to
know this like ah man my boys had a
rough week wasn't to make sure you're
all right
I appreciate that of my questions
mountain climbing we're not be amazing
on that note we will see you all next
week bye